I have a rule with all of my friends
which is there's no crying alone
no crying alone no crying alone okay but
if you are in a state where that level
of emotion if you start talking about
something that you know tears are going
to follow you immediately pick up the
phone and call me or somebody else and
there's no crying alone it's just not
allowed and
um the willingness to allow someone to
sit in mud with you is the is what it is
to be human I think it is it is the
greatest honor and I've been I've been
thinking about this a lot lately which
is you know when our friends are
struggling our instinct is to rescue
them to pull them out of the mud to fix
to fix and if you're the one sitting in
the mud when somebody attempts to fix
even if it's well intentioned it is the
it is a horrible feeling
just don't do that you're making it
worse
and what true friendship is is not the
desire to fix or pull the friend out of
the mud who you really want to see out
of the mud
but it's your willingness to sit in the
mud with them to get in the mud in terms
of and say
this sucks you know and it's not fun
being in the mud with them you don't
want to get in the mud with them
um but you choose to get in mud with
them until they're ready to say can we
get out now
but you sit there with them and that's a
friend of mine who he's one of those
folks
I hadn't talked to him in a while and I
called him up and be like what are you
up to I haven't talked in a while and he
he opened up and it was intense
and
I was like why didn't you call me
he's like I didn't want to bother you
and the end of our the way we ended the
phone call
is I said I didn't say I'm always here
I'll be here
you know I took my go on sort of
mentality and the way we ended the phone
call was like listen
um and he's he's depressed and he's in a
bad place the way we ended the phone
call is I said listen
um don't be an
and deny me the honor of being there for
you
like don't you have no right
to deny
very teary day today
[Applause]